[Music]
now we got elon cutting his hair
[ __ ] is up with that look at this going
for the richard smith is this new
dude he
went straight to what what bald
fade on the side isn't that i mean like
he looks like french like
the last time i saw a haircut like this
was
2014 2015. yeah it's pretty wild i like
how this is the only picture too that
i've seen of this haircut
is this like from a paparazzi or what
i went to [ __ ] craigs in west
hollywood you ever been there nah
it's like on melrose it's like one of
the places that's known i guess for
celebrities going there and there was
like nine paparazzi outside when i left
so wild i haven't actually seen that in
person just waiting yeah just waiting
like all of them like talking to each
other and
nine cameras around their necks and
ugh i was like who do you think is gonna
show up here
damn
we should go back with cutouts of like
like
they're like excuse me sir move okay
you can just get maybe get just sir
please move your boss might wanna you
might just move over
please please just you might wanna
please sir ryan's toys is exiting the
building please move aside sir
ryan's toys
drunk as hell yeah [ __ ] 10 year old
wasted they say creator burnout is
[ __ ] fake it's real man
so sad
we should go back with cutouts of like
real stars and then just like drop down
like
just pulling up to craigs with ryan
gosling
and ryan
[Laughter]
i'm here with all the expendables cass
i should have done that when i was
leaving
just
oh [ __ ] it's it's ryan gosling
just to try and trick him just into
getting one shot at him yeah yeah
i was gonna say who do i look like
you ask them that who do i like
hey
i am him let's go yeah
come on dude let's go come on what do
you look like one [ __ ] picture grab
his camera just kick one [ __ ] picture
he's like hey let go
you
look like
a long-haired guy um nah lord farquaad
yeah
oh my god is that lord farquaad what who
said that
who's the [ __ ] guy that i don't like
uh
ted whatever his name is the show that
got all the emmys
ted lasso yeah you slicked it you could
oh oh uh
i mean i like him i don't like i don't
like his acting that much but people say
sometimes i look like him yeah
remember is that ted lasso it's crazy
how much mickey rourke used to look like
him before he got punched up
did he
yeah mickey rory he bombed out on his
acting career he became a boxer no way
and because he was a pretty boy all the
boxers would make a point to [ __ ]
they knew he came from hollywood they
beat the [ __ ] out of his face look at
the second one
no no go back
even
below that yeah that one
oh my god yeah but that's what he looks
like now
oh he looks pretty bad now but oh yeah
he had a matching plastic surgery right
i mean he had some but i think it's like
you know having to punch that face i
think it was like to sort of maybe
like alleviate some of what boxing did
um was he a good boxer i don't think he
was that great that good
um so what happened to his acting career
why did he bomb out i forget he says he
has a crazy story like i want to say
like he
there's like some up and down thing
where he like was in hollywood and then
he
was like digging trenches for like
literal like hard blue-collar labor and
then
you know you're still trying to be an
actor and
i've always been curious to like read
more hmm
what the [ __ ] mickey rorick 62 knocks
out boxer half his age
why is he doing boxing again
why would he do that
oh
i thought yeah i was pretty sure he
boxed at a young age though
i don't know maybe i'm just starting
looking forward to mickey rourke jake
paul coming up no jake paul tyrone has
dropped out yeah yeah
but [ __ ] now jake paul will be
finally stepped up
then mickey rourke has stepped out
because he's too [ __ ] old so jake
will be fighting an uh an mta transit
supervisor
[ __ ] subway train engineer
the dude dustin poirier is fighting um
next week
the dude who uh
uh
connor broke his leg yeah yeah he's
fighting this week saturday oh yeah this
saturday yeah
yeah i'm kind of stuck for that
connor um
there's some picks going around he's
juice dude he looks weird
he's 190 pounds i think oh i thought he
was like 180. go to his uh instagram and
just like click on the first picture of
that carousel he posted it's he does he
doesn't look like himself yeah he looks
like someone else entirely it's so crazy
um
yeah he's uh
he
is a totally different person now look
at his face yeah thick ass boy
he's
juiced [ __ ] yolks why is he so
big
uh i think he just wants to be steroids
he's definitely on some [ __ ] he looks
huge right there yeah he didn't even
look like himself there look at that one
look at his face
oh bro he looks not look like him looks
like thanos yeah just like round because
a compound can be kind of created from
like nothing like
and not every like
no athletic commission knows the effects
of every compound ever
it's kind of crazy it's pretty easy to
get into athletics and if you have a
designer
drug you can be writing no problem
pretty
not no problem but if you have if you
know the right people yeah but these
drugs are like untested
yeah yeah you don't know what they're
gonna do to you
um but
what he was saying and i don't want to
mince it but in the case of jon jones he
was kind of putting forward whoa what
was that
he just kind of put it forward that
john took something thinking that it was
a clean designer steroid
and
it it was tainted with something else
and then the effect of that tainted
something
is what got him caught
but he could have he
probably just if not for that
contamination he could have gone
into competition no issue
yeah
and he was talking it's kind of
interesting how like some roids suppress
your testosterone
like i think everyone knows that but
how that suppression
um
it's crazy like your body will be
performing at an optimal rate but it's
not producing
any testosterone oh because it's getting
it from the drugs yeah oh i see yeah
[Music]
so so wild
yeah so i want to do rides
you